if a quasar or a star's billions of
light-years away how do we calculate
that distance of light makes billions of
years to reach us ooh
because the universe is older than that
and we waited around for it to get here
and it finally got here
and the light that reaches us is like
that left that quasar back at the
beginning of the universe so the stuff
that sent us light that hasn't gotten
here yet we don't see those objects but
as well we will eventually as the
universe gets older those object we will
see them being born yes they will rise
up out of the firmament of the cosmos
and their light will show up to us and
we'll say there's an object being born
now that the universe and our cosmic
horizon has enveloped their existence
and the universe is old enough for its
light to reach us we gotta go